one of the most important duties of any
government is to keep its citizens safe
this is why the Home Secretary pretty
Patel he's right to say the is Brad
Shamima begum cannot come back to
Britain the campaign by her legal team
to depict her as a victim and turn her
into an object of sympathy is a gross
distortion of the truth this woman
betrayed Britain betrayed our fellow
citizens rejected the freedoms and
comforts afforded to her by life in 21st
century London instead she chose to go
and live in an Islamist supremacist
death cult that enslaves uzd women
beheads charity workers and shows utter
contempt for the values of the Western
world the idea is a helpless woman who
had no responsibility for her actions is
an insult to the victims of is it would
be reckless to allow her back into
Britain how can we be sure she won't
radicalize other women and why should
the taxpayer have to pay for mi5 to keep
her under constant surveillance
she's made her - had a bed she can lie
in it do you know all the conversations
I have on that radio show I present this
is the one that I go back and forth on
and sometimes I'm totally with you and
sometimes home totally against you and
virtually everything you said I
absolutely underscore save for this one
fact which I always think makes us just
hold up here if we hadn't allowed anyone
else back into the country there might
be an argument
I understand there's around 400 jihadis
some of whom were actually possibly
active so these are men who took up arms
on behalf of is if we're able to bring
them back and in some instances try to
prosecute and in some instances just got
and I know there's a cost involved and I
get it and it seems faintly ridiculous
but if we can bring actual jihadists
back and we feel confident that we can
protect our citizens why in the case of
this woman for whom I have little
sympathy say for the loss of her
children of course I agree she was 15
but she knew where she was going she's
older now I have no sympathy but I
cannot for the life of me see how we
bring some back but we can't bring her
back well it's a different
administration now frankly with Loras
Johnson
Priti Patel in the Home Office but the
idea that she was an innocent over there
there is reports have come out of Syria
saying she was in the morality police
enforcing the dress code holding a
machine gun stitching suicide bombers
into explosive vessel a colonic so they
couldn't get out of them without
detonating the explosions and Europol
the EU agency has said returning to
Hadees are a terrorist I get it I mean
there's obviously just need to say these
are all alleged obviously well yeah but
but if we've allowed your had its bang
Andrew why can't we allow the bride back
we shouldn't have allowed no by the way
we shouldn't allowed them we are not and
the worrying thing is where are they but
worrying thing is only ten percent of
them we think have been prosecuted
that's disturbing and where are we going
to allow this woman to live do you want
to live in X or two you'll of course two
hundred North Street during your street
Carol Fermi you want to in your street
so that would you have a living in next
door to you know if she's done anything
wrong do we have evidence of her
actually committing any crime I think
anybody who joins Islamic state which is
a death cult which murders and kills and
is its whole ethos is to bring down the
way of life of the West they have
committed a crime and now of course you
know the government has changed the law
if she'd gone out there now she would
face an automatic 10-year jail soon so
she had committed crime a lot of them
this isn't about who she is this is
about who we are now we talk often about
how people need to respect our laws
under our laws a fifteen year old girl
is a minor if she is married as she was
to a terrorist over over in Syria she is
being groomed she is a child she's a
child abuse victim now for us and the
second issue is do you think regardless
of of how bad she is let's say she's
completely evil she is do you think we
as a country should be exporting our
criminals to other countries I do not
want these criminals back in this
country because I think that there are
serious terrorists sort of a death cult
yeah let's just remind people what they
did they
hacked men's heads off in the eyes of
the world they burned people alive they
they buried women and children alive but
not before raping them first and the
very idea that the women who married
these guys who saw all this and as
Andrew was just quoted were actually
involved in somebody's crime you can't
just say that that you know that we have
to be civilized about it why should we
she did say she was asking that first
interview about the beheadings and she
said she said I'm okay with it
it's islamically allowed her back I
think we can all agree that Islamic
state group tasks and abhorrent and I
absolutely reprehensible what they did
in Iraq and Syria especially Begum she's
a 15 year old clearly she was
radicalized in the UK Antony Lloyd the
Times journalist who interviewed her
said she even then she showed up four
years after joining us on that stage she
showed clear signs of being radicalized
of being groomed and she should be deer
addict alized but I think the key thing
here is that we do not get to decide who
is a citizen in who isn't on the basis
of our feelings that's just not how the
rule of law works we do not get to make
people stateless it is in the UN
Declaration of Human Rights it is one of
the most fundamental rights is the right
to citizenship and we do not get to make
anybody also the British Nationality Act
says it says you can be deprived of your
citizenship if it is not conducive to
the public good and her presence in
Britain is not conducive 2014 when
Theresa May introduced that amendment
she did it on the basis of people who
were not born in the UK I'm not saying
it was right I think it was deplorable
anyway but but specifically the caveat
that she gave we have not applied to
just want it let's just here let's hear
from the woman herself talking to Sky
News this year
watch me from everything I've been
through you know when I write I didn't
know why I was going into and I left in
various interviews has been put to
Shamima whether or not she was actively
involved with Isis and she has
categorically denied it but I bring you
back to the main point let's say she's
evil let's say she's she's a terrorist
do we have the right as a country to
export our criminals to other countries
say they're not our problem even though
she was raised here even though we are
the ones who will allowed her to be
radicalized and allowed her to be saying
this is our fault
that she decided to leave this country
I'm saying that if we if it is our
responsibility to ensure that vulnerable
people are not exposed to terrorist
propaganda on the gaming are you saying
that because she was 15 years old she
didn't know the difference between right
and wrong she didn't know it was wrong
to hack someone's head off she didn't
know it was wrong to burn someone who
was going to be in a cave said that she
was radicalized and listen she is a
British citizen she's our responsibility
in the same way that we would not want
other countries Louis Callahan from The
Sunday Times interviewed a whole load of
jihadi brides from Britain and she said
most of them were lying through their
teeth when they said they had rejected
Isis and our security services here
already have said that when they come
back they are very likely to have been
right they're very likely to still be
radicalized more importantly it's going
to be very hard to gather evidence
against them to bring a prosecution
because it's impossible to do and indeed
Femi you say she was a 15 year old she
was only 15 oh there's a 16 year old to
whom the whole world is listening and
that forced me to go in the pouring rain
and recycle different boxes so we could
listen to one 16 year old with another
15 it's just some naive
kitty who didn't know I wonder in this
country between 2017 and 80 we had 2009
people under the age of 15 who had to go
into an anti-terrorism program in this
country that's these are kids of 14 15
13 who are radicalized here so let's not
pretend that they can't be that they
can't believe what is what they're doing
nobody's pretending anything this is
coming from let's look at dal Babu
actually the former chief superintendent
of the Metropolitan Police let's have a
look at what he says this young woman
has been spectacularly foolish and I've
listened to the interviews and I was
shocked to hear like everybody else some
of the things she was saying but this
was a 15 year old child and we have to
remember that she's lost three children
three three children have died while
she's been out there and we need to be
looking at what our responsibilities do
we dumped people who we have concerns
about on the rest of the world and leave
them to fester and become radicalized
and cause danger across the world or do
we take our responsibilities as a
country and I think that point about
dumping people we have concerns about on
the rest of the world is true in and of
itself but it's also about the values
that we want to live by and the examples
that we set around the world which is
equally important